talk about layovers of the rich and
famous Hollywood power couple Kristen
Bell and Dax Shepard getting tossed out
of Boston's airport with no available
hotels within 50 miles after attempting
to camp out at the gate during a nine
hour delay
yeah don't enter your bedroom
350 but then you went and you spent a
little bit more I think 153 for bed
sheets oh my God okay so we're at six
hundred dollars could have been a really
nice hotel but they're all taken 600 a
night to stay at Boston International
I mean if you run into a weather delay
the airline is not going to take care of
you it's all bets are off so if the
celebs aren't safe nobody is despite
showering Airlines with billions experts
say get ready for a decade of persistent
flight cancellations and delays
America's hard hat wearing
Transportation secretary mayor Pete
booty judge likes to pretend that he's
fixed everything you guys
it's clear that some of the work we've
done in the short term has paid off we
are holding the airlines accountable for
anything under their control they're
running a schedule that they can't
service because they don't have the
staff to do it we're going to hold them
accountable for that yeah speaking of
accountability if you're thinking about
hitting up one of those nude beaches in
Europe hope you already have your
passport there is a massive backlog with
some folks waiting up to four months
four months Harold four months so Harold
I don't want to come at you all hard you
know I just I need to know I know mayor
Pete is your guy and and you have
presidential hopes pinned all over him
like pin the tail on the Donkey he is a
mule for the airline industry I think he
is carrying their water it's
embarrassing there's no accountability
and I blame everything on him what say
you Harold Ford Jr
so I've not been a fan of how he's
handled some of these things I don't
think he's a stooge for the for the
airlines but I don't think they're being
serious about the issues that we have
there's no doubt these things are over
subscribed these these airlines are I
should say these these plane rods are
and it's largely because a lot of things
that we've talked about around the table
there's so many advertising and
marketing things that they're doing and
they can't they can't withstand it he's
right there but what he's what he's not
right about is according to our
according to the stuff we've looked at
today we are 32 000 Pilots mechanics and
air traffic control is short that's
where the focus needs to be
um if we're going to relieve people's
student loans we ought to relieve the
student loans for those who want to go
into these professions because we have
such a need there and then you hold the
airlines accountable where he's right
about hold them accountable for not
doing all this excessive marketing that
they can't where they can't meet those
demands now I don't understand why you
can't stand an airport if you're
supposed to be on a plane it's nine
hours delayed no fault of your own and
you can't get a hotel room at least
those celebrities could afford one but
they couldn't they didn't want to go to
150 miles away so what what should
everyday Americans do who booked their
book their their their their their
flights believing they're going to take
off on time and get to their
destinations and they don't what are we
expect them to do I'd love to hear the
Secretary of Transportation or the
airlines or the airport speak to that
yeah as opposed to all of the holding
people account of all the other stuff
they're talking about doing let's let's
be accountable to these passengers well
like Greg Gutfeld Jesse if Pete booty
judge doesn't like to fly commercial he
likes to fly a prize I thought you're
going to say they're both short
for that
shortage for another sure there it goes
it's very sad uh we've had a pollen
shortage for years but then during covid
a lot of the airlines were encouraged to
let people retire early or just fire
them if they wouldn't get vaccinated
right so travel stopped they fired and
everybody retired and then all of a
sudden when it picked back up they're
looking around like hey where is
everybody and it takes about two years
and 100 G's to train a pilot plus they
do all the airline maintenance overseas
so that's also another issue Dax
is a man and he should have had a plan I
don't know what that plan was but that
right there is not a plan
if I was his wife I would be livid now
you're a celebrity and as a celebrity
you have to carry yourself with dignity
if I'm someone walking through the
airport and I see a celebrity with a
neck pillow sleeping on the floor that's
not a good look for us so us you better
get it together Dax but in a way though
it's kind of sweet because when you see
a celebrity passed out with a neck
pillow you think you know what we're all
in this together this even happens to
Dax yeah Dax Shepard so is it Dax or Dak
Dax I'm sorry yeah Dak Prescott yeah
yeah that's Jack Rambo the x is silent
exactly right
um so Shannon one of the other big
hurdles people are having having to
cancel trips and losing thousands of
dollars because their passports have not
arrived we're hearing there's up to a
four month backlog to get your passport
because a lot of people have never had
one they have Wanderlust now because
they were cooped up for three years so
what should people do if they if they
mailed in their application and they
haven't gotten their magic book people
are freaking so they're calling their
members of Congress you'll know about
this because they're asking and these
offices on the Hill are telling us they
are getting inundated with people who
are like oh yeah now I want to go
somewhere I never had this passport can
you help me
um same thing with a lot of people that
were let go retired there was a huge
backlog during kovid of people at the
state department who can handle this
kind of stuff they're trying to catch up
by the way my husband did get kicked out
of the Boston airport one time too
because he was stuck there overnight and
he thought I'll just go sleep on some
chairs and they told him oh no sir and
he's trying to hide from the security
guards just walk around like a zombie he
sat outside on his bag he said he
watched rats and Drug deals until he was
allowed back into the airport like five
o'clock in the morning then on the
Pilot's issue too someone in my family
who may be a retired military pilot went
to work for one of the big Airlines
loved it great job was called by the
military and said we are so desperate
for experienced Pilots is there any
chance you would come back so he now has
a sharing deal with his commercial
airline and the military so we can apply
for the military for a few more years so
there's a shortage all over there yeah
you can't recruit yeah that's a very
small base of employees so Greg I know
that in just a few short years you're
probably going to be the transportation
secretary
thinking about it it's on my list my
bucket list yep I know are you flirted
with Solutions but what would you do
well here's the thing I mean my problem
with Fox News is the lies that we tell
those are not rich and famous people
I'm Kristen Bell and Dax Shepard
together make one Kearney Wilson all
right
and
bed sheets at the airport
that seems a little bit suspicious to me
I think this was all a little dance for
their Tick-Tock world oh yeah yeah by
the way you know you can't there are
countries where you don't need a
passport like Ukraine
so there they're down 32 000 pilots and
you know what scares me about that is
we're going to lower standards which is
what we did with the military and what
we did in some cases with the police
force you can actually see that with
some officers and their weight issues uh
they can't they can't chase criminals
because they're out of shape I worry
about the pilots and um it does kind of
feel like all the stuff that used to be
good is bad flying
the beach
Disney
movie theaters cities it's like America
has suddenly become the house on the
Block that stopped mowing its lawn
picking up the mail and the newspapers
they got a car on the blocks because
there's a new owner right and the new
and the new owner wasn't like the new
the owner before it really was proud of
that house you know like the little
elderly couple and they it was manicured
and it was well painted and and they had
the best Halloween candy and they were
and they made gingerbread cookies around
Christmas and the nice little they were
so sweet they had they had a pristine
car it was probably a 1970s early 70s
Chevelle maybe a Studebaker but now they
moved maybe they passed on rip and said
now we have these just
disgusting people and you're seeing the
cities go to hell you're seeing culture
go to hell you're seeing Transportation
flying every infrastructure element of
life going to hell language I'm sorry I
Friday and I want to get drunk I thought
you already wanted to get drunk yes yes
intense that's the way we're going all
right we do have breaking news President
Biden finally talking about the
granddaughter that he has shunned we
just mentioned it we'll hear more of it
stay with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else